[Musique]
et ses invités aujourd'hui c'est vous
marie thomas peut naître bonjour bonjour
bienvenue à vous sur ce plateau et
françois-xavier des stores bonjour et
bienvenue vous êtes tous les deux
réalisateurs et votre dernier film
pierraille 44 est un film france 24 il
sera diffusé samedi prochain sur notre
antenne on en est fiers parce que c'est
un film important on parle d'événements
vieux de près de 80 ans mais qui résonne
encore aujourd'hui et pour cause nous
sommes le 1er décembre 1944 dans le camp
de thiaroye au sénégal c'est en banlieue
de dakar des dizaines de soldats
africains qu'on appelait à l'époque les
tirailleurs sont exécutés par des
officiers de l'armée française ces
hommes qui ont combattu pour la france
et dont certains sortent de captivité
réclament le paiement de leurs soldes on
va détailler dans un instant selon la
version officielle il y a eu une
mutinerie sauf que sauf que non des
historiens ont bien travaillé le sujet
je pense à armelle mabon et martin moore
en particulier que vous retrouverez dans
le documentaire et non ce n'était pas
une mutinerie s'est ces soldats s'est
réclamé simplement d'être payé leur
salaire leur solde de captivité puisque
beaucoup étaient prisonniers il
demandait simplement à recevoir leur dû
et ils ont été
rassembler un matin par les officiers
français est tué sur sur une place au
milieu de ce camp militaire qui était
censé être un camp de transit un lieu où
il devait rester quelques jours avant de
pouvoir rentrer chez eux avec leur
salaire et malheureusement il n'en sont
jamais ressorti qui étaient ces hommes
et d'où venaient-ils et surtout combien
sont ils à avoir été utile et et combien
d'entre eux ont été tués par leurs
frères d'armes ce jour là c'est encore
une zone d'ombré
ces hommes étaient pour l'essentiel
d'anciens prisonniers de guerre qui
avaient été enrôlés souvent de force en
1939-40 pour pour la france pour
combattre aux côtés des français au
moment de la seconde guerre mondiale
contrairement à ce que dit l'histoire
officielle absolument et ils ont
combattu avec mais il ya eu la défaite
en juin 40 et la plupart d'entre eux ont
été faits ont été faits prisonniers
non pas en territoire allemand parce que
les allemands refusaient la présence des
noirs sur leur propre sol ce qui est
déjà éminemment raciste mais prisonnier
sur le territoire français certains ont
participé à des activités de résistance
à la fin de la guerre ils se sont évadés
de ces de ces camps de prisonniers et en
1944 en novembre 1944 on leur a on leur
a donné l'ordre de rentrer chez eux en
les privant quelque part de la victoire
parce qu'à l'époque la france n'était
pas encore sortie victorieuse de la
guerre mais c'était en train de se jouer
et ils sont ils étaient environ entre
1300 et 1700 à embarquer de morlaix en
bretagne vers vers dakar le nombre de
tués est encore mystérieux aujourd'hui
le bilan officiel fait état de 35 morts
35 blessés mais les archives sont
parcellaires et contradictoires
incohérente on parle parfois de 70 morts
mais les historiens que marie citée à
l'instant nous parle plutôt de plusieurs
centaines de morts il s'agit là il ne
faut pas peur de le dire d'un crime de
masse un crime d'état
donc selon la version officielle il y à
une mutinerie provoqué par donc là
pardon de la la la la réclame de cette
soldes promise à ses qui était en fait
un retour sur la seule qu'ils auraient
dû avoir mais ils étaient en captivité
pendant
enfin sur le continent européen s'il n'y
a pas but une mutinerie que s'est il
passé
que ce qu'on peut déduire des archives
puisqu'elles sont beaucoup de ces
beaucoup des documents des rapports
militaires ont été écrits après les
événements donc on peut se douter que
ceux ci ont été aussi écrit pour cacher
ce qui s'est réellement passé puisqu'on
y trouve énormément d'incohérences
ce qu'on arrive à reconstituer à travers
les différents rapports c'est que ses
soldats ont été réveillés un matin
le 1er décembre au matin à l'aube et
rassemblés sur une place de ce camp où
ils ont été encerclés par des auto
mitrailleuses des chars parle d'armes
très lourde on parle d'armes lourdes où
il s'agit pas de simples fusils donc il
y avait un service d'ordre il y avait
les officiers qui étaient présents et
les militaires français ont ensuite
écrit dans le rapport que les
tirailleurs étaient armés et qu'ils
étaient en train de se rebeller ce qui a
été démontré qui est totalement faux il
n'y avait pas d'armes ils ont été
rassemblés et ils ont été mitraillés par
par l'armée française et
on s'est même qui a eu un seul blessé du
côté du service du service d'ordre
mais se blesser et ça a été démontré par
la suite lors du procès qui a eu lieu a
été blessé par une balle qui a fait un
ricochet qui venait du service d'ordre
donc si ces tirailleurs été réellement
armés on peut penser qu'il se serait
rebellé on peut penser qu'il y aurait
aussi des blessés voire des morts du
côté de l'armée française qui n'est pas
le cas donc voilà c'est clairement
c'était clairement un piège ils ont été
encerclés et assassiné il ya eu
préméditation
le fait de le fait de faire venir de
saint louis et d'ailleurs des armes très
lourde pour encercler le camp est et tué
ses hommes prouve qu'il ya préméditation
et derrière par la suite ce qui est ce
qui est
très dur à accepter encore aujourd'hui
c'est que
l'armée française a donc tiré sur ses
propres soldats
à arrêter les survivants
les a jugés ensemble en procès quelques
temps après dans une parodie de justice
les a jugés déshonoré emprisonnés et
ensuite caché le crime de masse pour le
déguiser en mutinerie on va revenir dans
quelques instants sur ce qu'il s'est
passé après dans l'histoire et l'
enquête que mène les personnages de
votre film cette histoire tragique
s'inscrit dans sept de ces africains
donc on a longtemps appelé tirailleurs
envoyé au front sur une période d'un
siècle à peu près jusqu'à la
décolonisation et dont le sort a pour
beaucoup été tragique est un moment
extrêmement émouvant dans votre film
entre autres entre autre moment c'est le
témoignage d'un vieil homme qui est dans
son lit un vieux monsieur qui s'appelle
adolphe serre qui qui raconte il était
témoin en l'occurrence il a été témoin
de ce qui s'est passé à thiant en
décembre 44 et il est interrogé par
l'historien que l'on suit de votre fils
mais voilà ce qu'il dit lui celui qui a
combattu pour la france de ce que la
france a fait de lui on écoute
est ce que vous vous avez entendu les
coups de feu de la gare on attendait
nettement les coups de feu honnêtement
c'est pas loin
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est la guerre
c'est après qu'on nous a expliqué
c'est sur galère ne réclamer que le but
les indemnités que leur devait pendant
la guerre
pour ne pas leur donner ça on les a
tuées
comme nous avons nous un pays si
ce n'est pas normal je m'excuse du terme
en de vous le dire la france est ingrate
envers nous
que pour nous les jeunes d'afrique est
on a aimé la france on a aimé la preuve
on s'est engagé dans l'armée parce que
on croyait que
l'histoire de la tanaisie t'es pas mal
dans l'armée au contraire
presque la majeure partie des officiers
étaient des racistes
est majeure partie des officiers étaient
des racistes des mots très forts
oui et c'est vrai c'est vrai en tout cas
dans ce qu'on a pu dans ce qu'on a pu
lire notamment comme françois-xavier
parler de cette parodie de procès qui a
eu lieu après après le crime
c'était donc le procès pour s'en prendre
à 34 tirailleurs qui ont été accusés
d'avoir mené la mutinerie évidemment ils
ont clamé leur innocence
mais tout ce qu'on a pu rédiger comme
rapport comme recherche pour trouver les
causes pour pouvoir les accuser et
finalement c'était empreint d'un racisme
incroyable quand on quand on lit les
documents c'est
disons que nous on est tombé des nues de
de voir à quel point on pouvait parler
encore du tirailleur yabon comment
comment on pouvait les accusés d'avoir
d'avoir séduit les femmes françaises et
par ailleurs il y avait aussi pas mal de
misogynie en plus du racisme puisqu'on a
aussi accusé ces femmes françaises
d'avoir détourné ses hommes pour pour
qu'ils prennent conscience de leurs
droits donc voilà on est vraiment face à
un crime raciste il faut le dire c'est
c'est une injustice totale et comme on
le voit cette injustice
a perduré au fil des années elle ne
s'est pas arrêtée en 44 bien sûr 80 ans
plus tard donc aucune réparation bien
sûr pour les familles de ces tirailleurs
tuer qui n'ont d'ailleurs pour la
plupart corrigez moi si je me trompe
aucunement eu de récupérer la dépouille
de leurs deux lors de leurs 2 c de ces
personnes qui ont été tuées françois
hollande est allé attirail en 2014 il a
reconnu la responsabilité dans l'âme de
la france dont je le cite la répression
sanglante expression qui a fait tiquer
les historiens et les descendants parce
qu'elle allait encore une fois dans le
sens d'une répression d'une mutinerie
c'est ça quand on part d'une répression
sanglante
on évoque la responsabilité ces
tirailleurs or comme on vous l'a dit
c'est tirailleurs était désarmé et ce
sont des termes qui sont qui sont faux
la réalité c'est que c'est que ça fait
plus de 60 70 ans que les enfants et
petits-enfants de tirailleurs de ces
tirailleurs ouest africains qui sont
tombées à tiarei se bat pour essayer de
réhabiliter la mémoire de leur père ou
de leur grand-père il y à des archives
qui n'ont pas été encore ouvertes
qui n'ont jamais vu le jour on les
historiens n'y ont pas accès alors est
ce que ces archives ont été détruites
est ce qu elles ont été cachées quelque
part est ce qu'elles auront été on ne
sait pas on ne sait pas où sont ces
archives mais ce qui est clair c'est que
c'est très très étonnant parce que toute
l'histoire
de la f1 et en particulier de dakar à ce
moment là a été très très bien reporté
et notamment l'histoire militaire mais
au sujet de tiarei et autour du camp
militaire on n'a aucune information on
ne sait pas combien de tirailleurs ont
débarqué à dakar le 27 novembre on ne
sait pas combien stationner donc dans le
camp de sireuil et on n'a aucune
information on ne connaît pas leurs noms
c'est vraiment des des trous des béances
non dans les archives qui sont
incompréhensibles que vous démontrez
dans ces chiffres dans ce film voilà
pour quelques éléments de fond et on va
laisser bien sûr les téléspectateurs de
le découvrir je réponds parle de la
forme de votre du clan documentaire le
choix que vous faites dans ce film c'est
de suivre trois jeunes qui s'appelle
aïcha maggie et babacar ils sont tous
les trois originaires de thiais roj et
ils tentent chacun à leur manière de ne
pas laisser cette histoire tombé dans
l'oubli ils posent beaucoup de questions
les bonnes questions d'ailleurs
notamment à l'historien qu'on a croisé à
l'instant c'est un film qui parle de
transmission et de réappropriation aussi
oui parce que c'est une mémoire qui est
très vive en fait tant que temps que
cette histoire n'aura pas été écrite
mise à plat qu'on n'aura pas regarder en
face la mémoire des événements
continuera de vivre et notamment là bas
quand on quand on est allé pour la
première fois à tiarei on a été
particulièrement impressionné par des
jeunes lycéens qu'on a rencontrés qui
skie qui faisait un avec leur professeur
de français à un petit cours de théâtre
en atelier pour parler de cette de cette
mémoire de thiaroye 44 et ils nous ont
interpellés ils nous ont ils nous ont
demandé d'en parler et il nous faisait
mais c'est pas possible qu'on ne sache
pas ce qui s'est passé ici tous les
jours quand on va à l'école il est
possible qu'on marche sur des cadavres
on ne sait pas où sont enterrés nos
ancêtres tant qu'on n'aura pas écrit
l'histoire tant qu'on n'aura pas
raconter on pourra pas se construire
nous mêmes et ils avaient 15-16 ans il
nous disait ça et donc à chaque fois
qu'on y est retourné à tiarei on allait
auprès de cette jeunesse et c'est
finalement avec ces trois jeunes qu'on a
rencontrés au fil des années qu'on a
construit qu'on a construit ce film
parce que euh on a un message cette
colère cette rage cette frustration
qu'ils ont besoin d'exprimer et on
voulait vraiment leur donner la parole
mais pas de pad pardon change sans
justice en deux mots c'est aussi voilà à
propos de cette mémoire qui dont
l'équipe qui se perd cette mémoire
vivante et qu'il s'agit de faire
perdurer effectivement sur d'autres
générations oui et puis avec leurs
propres moyens d'expression ou à défaut
de connaître la vérité qu'elles figurent
dans les livres d'histoire ou dans le
discours politique ou dans les actes
politiques cette mémoire elle vit encore
dans la culture dans l'art dans et en
particulier dans le hip hop là bas au
sénégal donc c'était important pour nous
qu'il puisse aussi se saisir de sa pour
créer quelque chose et la faire vivre
merci beaucoup de me permettre une
transition parfaite on va se quitter
avec les voix de aïcha et maggie qui
sont deux des personnages principaux du
film qui chante toutes les deux en
mémoire des oubliés de thiais roye
tireur 44 donc un film france 24 à voir
samedi à 22h10 sur notre antenne merci
beaucoup aux mariés thomas planète et
françois-xavier des stores d'être venu
nous en parler
ben voilà ce que c'est on va se quitter
en musique et je vous laisse donc
découvrir ce film samedi prochain dans
reporter le dock porté notamment par
loïc berrou éclaire obs on se retrouve
juste après la pause avec damien ok
[Musique]
go
retrouver dans steam et demi du faux à
ce moment là
un
peu morose
[Musique]